Donald Trump hetner Trump is has
reportedly told aides that he is afraid
that journalists will deliberately try
to infect him with you-know-what on Air
Force One there's a report and Vanity
Fair which is outrageous if it's even
ten percent true and we have every
reason to believe that it's completely
accurate among other things Donald Trump
is melting down over the idea that
somebody on Air Force one might
weaponize the virus against him and
tried to deliberately infect him while
on his government airplane Donald Trump
has also been spotted over the weekend
refusing to shake the hand of a
supporter the supporter holds out his
hand as what you're seeing on the video
Trump says something presumably we're
not supposed to be shaking hands anymore
and then the supporter kind of offers
his elbow and they do an elbow bump
instead and so the reason I'm telling
you this is not that I want Donald Trump
to get infected or anything of the sort
although he may already be as people are
speculating I don't know how likely that
is the reason I'm telling you this is
that it is proof that Trump is lying all
the time about this Trump publicly says
everything's under control
there's nothing to fear it's no big deal
it's overblown we're on top of it the
Dems are exaggerating but privately
Trump clearly knows this is bad
privately Trump is worried that
journalists on his airplane will
weaponize the infection against him
privately Trump isn't shaking hands with
people Trump knows it's serious which
makes his public denials all the more
transparently dishonest and immoral if
Trump claims this is like the flu and we
should treat it like the flu why is he
refusing handshakes he didn't do that
previously when the flu was going around
which it is now as well when Trump says
we should keep going to work mostly it's
contained Dems are exaggerating and then
privately he says the press may be
trying to kill me by breathing on me
that doesn't suggest he really believes
it's under control because that is what
Donald Trump is suggesting here anyone
believe that Trump is thinking about how
to get Bernie or Biden infected I mean
is that even too dark for Trump to
consider or might I be on to something
there
Donald Trump claimed he would keep doing
his Magga or CagA rallies or whatever
they're being called at this point
because this isn't serious except when
you go to Donald Trump's website there
are no rallies scheduled scheduled under
the events page it says under rallies
none scheduled guys he knows it's
serious but he's lying to you he's not
doing rallies he's not shaking hands
with supporters he thinks the press will
weaponize the virus against him what
would be worse now this is actually a
real question would it be worse if Trump
was genuinely too dumb to know that this
is serious or is it worse that Trump
clearly knows it's serious and is simply
lying publicly but privately actually
melting down over this you tell me which
you think is actually worse I want to
hear from you let me know on Twitter at
D Pakman make sure you're following me
on Twitter what if you could read ten
books in just one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinka Stan what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books they condense them down into text
or audio that you can consume in 15
minutes blinka snakes sure that you're
getting all of the important core
insights from each book so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for there's a full
book you're thinking about buying you
can use blink as' to get a sample first
just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blinka Staz
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video